hey what's up guys my name is samuel
leeds and i'm going to show you how you
can literally
go to rightmove and find a two-bed house
and turn it into a four-bed hmo with
very high cash flow so firstly um if
you're looking for a hmo you want to go
to a kind of cheap area people go
wolverhampton doesn't work anymore
because there's article 4 in
wolverhampton
so just go somewhere slightly outside go
somewhere where there's no article 4.
so we're going to go to warsaw and there
is no article four in warsaw i'll check
this
uh warsaw and when you say how do you
find out the answer listen there's some
things you really can just google such
as
article 4 in warsaw and article 4
directions in
around warsaw is just here so there's
just a few streets literally some
some of these just like number 12
bradford street is article 4 direction
but
generally speaking of warsaw is not yet
article 4 which means you do not need
planning permission
to turn a property into a hmo
now you will need a license if it's a
five bed but if it's a four bed
you won't need a license and that's
generally the case across the uk if it's
a four bed hm and you don't need a
license if it's a five bed you do
so why do we want a two bed why don't we
find a three bed and turn it into a four
bed and the answer is
because three beds are really expensive
if you look at generally
properties let's do like almost 70 grand
up to 100
or 200 grand and if we look at just
three bed houses
three bed houses and uh search
and we can include uh we'll just do
newest newest listed
you can see that generally speaking
three bit houses
this one's 174 even the ones that look
like junk this one looks like junk
ugly house just added yesterday 130
grand
so you're talking about 130 grand added
yesterday
this one looks like junk and it's 200
grand whereas
a two bed house isn't gonna be like 200
grand it might be 130 but
you you're never gonna find a three bed
house in warsaw right now in 2020
uh you're never gonna find that um for a
hundred grand
whereas if we search a two bed house
because we want it we want it cheap
cheap cheap cheap cheap cheap buy low
rent high that's that's
that's my mantra buy low rent high with
a property manager nearby
so if we find a two bed
in warsaw for sale they're gonna
they will be much cheaper uh we'll do
this area only
price range i don't know 70 grand up to
130 grand
let's just let's do 90 grand actually
because if they're 70 grand
they're probably gonna need a lot of
work and i just can't be bothered to do
loads of work on houses right now
um okay let's see we just want a neat
straightforward
change over so straight away you can see
okay 130 grand for a two bed
uh 130 grand okay cool 130 grand but
we're searching for the highest price
let's see what we've got if we go lowest
price boom
97 grand boom nice at the same house
okay so they're much cheaper and how do
you turn one of these little
cheap 100 grand houses two bed houses
into a four bed hmo because we know if
we could get four rooms out of this
it's only a two bed at the moment but if
we could get four rooms out of this
we know we'd be laughing how so because
in warsaw
and i'm talking warsaw center this is
ws1 if we look on the map where this is
it's within this very center of warsaw
this is the little circle
town i know warsaw really well i grew up
here there's the train station this is
the so that is smack bang on the center
of warsaw
there's no article four it's a little
crappy two-bed house
if we could somehow get four luxury
rooms because if we look in warsaw right
now
flatmates there are people looking to
rent rooms in warsaw
right now like crazy but there's a
recession yeah there's a session but
look
a single room in warsaw new today 110
pound a week
that's 440 pounds every four weeks
that's probably like close to 500 pounds
a month
look 600 pound for a double room in
warsaw
new today 500 new today like so and
and i'm filming this um right now i
don't even know what the date is what's
the date today
day today and it's the morning i'm
filming
so it's 10th of september and it's the
morning right now i'm filming about 11
o'clock and we've got new people looking
today
looking to pay like four five six
hundred pounds a month for a room in
warsaw
so if people could if we could get four
rooms out of this
and inside make it luxury i mean right
now it's not luxury i mean look at this
damp okay this does need a bit of work
this does need a bit of work
but how do you turn it into a four bed
and it's very simple
i'm known for turning reception rooms
into your bedrooms by putting a bed in
it
this one's got a floor plan great
bedroom
bedroom now you might be thinking about
samuel you can turn that into a bedroom
but you need a communal room because for
it to be a hmo it needs a communal room
and the answer is it does need a
communal room to be a hmo
unless the bedrooms are 100 square feet
each if they're the bedrooms by law need
to be 70 square feet
and if they're 70 square feet you need a
communal room but if the bedrooms are
100 square feet
you don't need a communal room and guess
what
bedrooms that are two bed houses see if
it's a three bed if there was a third
bedroom here it'd be tiny tiny little
third bedroom whereas
two bed houses tend to be big bedrooms
so is this over a hundred square feet
yes
ten ten by thirteen eight considerably
over a hundred square feet
thirteen eight by ten four considerably
over
nine eight by ten five that's probably
just over a hundred square feet so all
we're gonna do
is we're going to whack a little a
little stood wall right here
and we're going to put a door here and
this is going to become a bedroom
and this is going to become a bedroom
all we need to do to turn this into a
bedroom is put a freaking bed in it
and then and then and they but samuel
they've got no communal bedroom they've
got no communal area
guess what 2020 no one cares we're not
social anymore we're anti-social
people just want to go in their bedroom
with super fast wi-fi
they don't even want a tv anymore they
just want an ipad
with super fast wi-fi so bedroom bedroom
bedroom bedroom
500 pounds a month 500 pounds a month
500 pounds a month 500 pounds a month
that's 2 000 pounds a month rent
for this little tiny hundred grand house
and
they'll share the kitchen and bathroom
you don't need a license there's no
planning permission needed because it's
not in an article four area
and and this there's loads of deals like
this this is just literally
like okay this house has been on the
market since 2019 september
it's been on the market a year do you
think we'd be able to get a below market
value deal on this yes
and it says offers over 100 maybe
they're in negative equity maybe we
could do a lease option agreement that's
another story
um anyway i don't want to get into it
into a rabbit hole right here
um see this was bought for 80 grand in
2006
like bottomed out bottomed out
like there's loads of houses like this
it's just crazy
um let's see this this house you see how
easy this is
this isn't like here's one i found
earlier i'm not even trying right now
what did they buy it for they bought it
for 29 grand in 1997. wow
997 property prices shot up but we don't
care about that right now we care about
the return on investment
so this house uh two reception rooms
two double bedrooms let's see the sizes
are they over 100 square feet
lounge is dining room is bedroom is
bedroom two is that could be four
bedrooms
and i know where this is on with
connell's i've bought many times through
connells
and this is uh just off the
wolverhampton road i've got clients i've
sold
houses here to clients hmos on
wolverhampton road
guess who they rent to nurses from the
manor hospital
cracking area for hmos you'd rent the
rooms out all day long maybe not for 500
pounds
maybe 400 pounds but that's still four
that's still 1600 pounds a month rent
if you did it as a single let you might
get 600 pounds a month rent
and there's just loads of deals like
this there's not enough duels yeah
because you don't know what you're
looking for
you don't know what you're looking for
let's look at this house this house
looks like it's in decent condition
nice big kitchen awesome uh same story
same story
it's in right in the center who's this
on with that she's on with i love homes
i've bought through isle of homes
i know how they think it's right bang in
the center of warsaw
we know that people are looking to rent
rooms in warsaw because we saw it on
spare room let's have a look at the
floor plan
again bedroom stood wall here by the way
stood will cost like 500 quid
put a fire door here bedroom and then
let's see
uh over 100 square feet bedroom over 100
square feet bedroom
now of course i need to view it i'm not
suggesting that you go and buy this
house
without viewing it geez i'm just giving
you the principle of how this works
so this is how you turn a two-bed house
into a four-bed hmo
and i hope you found this video helpful
you know what guys it takes me
most people hold this kind of thing so
secret most people do not share this
kind of thing you don't see any people
on youtube
sharing this kind of thing i put it all
out there i've been there done it got
the t-shirt continue to invest
and i just keep doing videos showing you
exactly how i'm doing it the ins and
outs so it takes me a lot of time and
effort to do this video so please do
show support by smashing the like button
subscribing and i'll be
if you do that i'll do more videos like
this thanks for watching